hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
i'm sorry it's time for the thursday
afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcasting
i'm just checking in on you i'm checking
in on you
joe six-pack you put your [ __ ] pants
on one leg at a time
and you can do no wrong
you can do no right you are not held
accountable
okay you do have a medical degree
sorry i'm just watching all of this uh
peripherally
i'm seeing all of this [ __ ] people
getting pissed of the government because
of these lockdowns which is
crushing businesses
and a lot of these [ __ ] guys you know
they go you know stand six feet apart
every [ __ ] mask on don't go out to
dinner and then what do they do
what do they do after all they yeah yeah
[ __ ] what do they do they go right
out and they sit down and [ __ ] get
dinner all right so everybody's like
well what the [ __ ]
that's like when your mother said
say no to drugs and you'd already looked
into her little [ __ ]
you know a little end table side little
drawer there
saw all her little mother's helpers in
there oh really ma
what you know you think we don't hear
you wandering around the [ __ ] halls
after you put us in bed
all right you pill popping two-faced
[ __ ] hypocrite
but you make a great pie and you are my
mother
and my religion says i need to respect
you
i need to honor my mother and father
haven't said that you're taking the
devil's aspirin
um i'm in a great [ __ ] mood
um to the point i'm combining so that
was a mash-up
of a song that never existed with yeah
dude uh what is that a yankee doodle
head or something all the doo daddy
old mcdonald old macdonald had now what
the [ __ ] dude
[Music]
one of those white prospector songs you
know
that you'd sing after you killed your
wife all right
i'll go get myself another one and the
next plot will
get me some gold um and that's the way
it was in the 1800s
um anyway i just uh just flew a
helicopter
i had a great time i flew uh a cadbury
g2 which is sort of a baby a star for
you
uh uh aviation people out there and the
the main rotor turns the other way so it
was kind of interesting so all the
pedal inputs were different all you have
to remember is that
with the european helicopters is your
left foot follows the collective for the
young people flying helicopters that's
the thing that looks like the emergency
brake
you know though we were doing neutral
drops and [ __ ] what do these call
that when you just grab the emergency
brake
yank it up and turn the steering wheel
in your chevy monza yes that was a car
for you youngsters out there
all right you know i tried to help uh
try to help tried to hype
an album um oh [ __ ] texting me now
uh from tim jones
all right and i [ __ ] it up so i got to
make sure that i got everything
in here okay this is what he sent me
said bill getting messages from a ton of
people laughing their asses off at that
pro at the promo of course cause i
[ __ ] it up thanks for spreading the
word
um and when the records are done
hopefully next month next month they're
gonna be done
so the guy's name is leroy powell
is the guy also with tim jones okay he
wanted me to know that he's played on
not only wheeler walker
this guy's like a legend so i i felt bad
that i didn't know his last name and i
and i only
said the wheeler walker thing which was
a fantastic album
uh but he's also done other stuff he's a
top session guitar
and pedal steel player for dave cobb and
many others
producing projects including sturgill
sampson
wheeler walker jr anderson ace shooter
jennings get over here
you sum [ __ ] uh cody jinx chris
isaac is that the guy and i will always
something or other or is that whitney
houston i'm just mashing up songs here
i don't want to fall in love well then
don't chris
quit complaining about it uh what are
you [ __ ]
a white drake
[Music]
i never heard a guy get so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] and be sad about it than drake i
mean what is the
problem it sounds like your life is
amazing uh league
you used to call me on myself so move on
to the next one you [ __ ] rock star
[ __ ] cry about it your mink coat what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to feel bad about
cody jinx chris isaac leanne womack
whoa mack barry gibb by the way the bg's
documentary is [ __ ] amazing and of
course
way back the old oak ridge boys i'll
tell them oak ridge more you give a
couple of guitars man i think i'm crazy
on your ass
uh he also co-wrote and produced whiskey
meyer's
first album so there you go the guy is a
beast and i you know i'm not i'm just
[ __ ] with you
with the southern accent i am actually a
closet
huge country music fan i like the old
guys
the old guys you know whose dads had had
[ __ ] some moonshine still
they knew how to fix cars and play a
couple of cowboy chords the next thing
you know they would write the saddest
song
ever i told you what's his face george
jones is my favorite
um come on in was it
was it something if you'd like to take
the grand tour
of a lonely home that once
was home sweet home golden ring
i listen all that [ __ ] the old [ __ ]
uh willie nelson
i love all of that [ __ ] i like the
outlaw ones i don't like the ones that
are trying to get become the next
president with all the family values i
like the ones that have a brick of weed
on their bus
and don't pay their taxes those are the
guys i like
um so anyway we got a link for that
uh the whiskey wolves of the west
www.whiskeywolvesofthewest.com
and they're putting out three uh
three albums next month i'm supposed to
be done by next month they get a little
sad up there
so i'm looking forward to that all right
now let's talk
nfl football
um did anybody watch that unbelievable
game
between the uh baltimore raven ravens
and the cleveland browns the cleveland
browns who are not only not your dad's
cleveland browns
not your grandfather's cle maybe your
grandfather's i would say your
great-grandfather's cleveland browns
this is a [ __ ] solid team and they
have not had a solid team
i don't think since like [ __ ] bernie
coza
you know so maybe it's your dad's when
he was a
kid right a little baby um
that [ __ ] game was like remember
those rocky movies where you're just
like dude this [ __ ]
those that would have knocked that guy
out and they kept fighting that's what
the end of the game was like
all right and it's a testament to the
level athlete that's out of the field at
least on the offensive side of the ball
and it's also a testament
to the dirty filthy work of jim irsay in
the whole nfl
where they're just like offense sells
this game because
back in the day joe montana just had to
be joe montana once
right two minutes left in the game good
no worries joe montana
right down the field defense would come
out stop the other team
joe would take three knees the game was
over that ain't the way the game's
played no more
it's not the way the game is played
anymore
the game is now [ __ ] insane
okay i i can't i lost
track of the amount of lead changes in
the final [ __ ] minute and 50
seconds it seemed it's like cleveland
scored
i think to tie the game all right
baker mayfield drives him down bam
ties up the [ __ ] game and then lamar
jackson's like oh really
oh is that what you're doing okay and
then he goes out there like joe montana
right down the field
right touchdown
now they're up seven and they cut to
baker mayfield and what is he doing
he's on the side nodding his head like
he's in a hollywood movie
like vince young back in the day in the
[ __ ] uh when they played uh usc in
that one of the greatest
what a great college games of all time
no it's like okay okay i see you joe
montana
and now i'm joel montana he goes right
down the field
bam touchdown
thankfully they went for the extra point
i'm like they're going to go for two
here and they're not going to get it
they go for extra point the ex they get
the extra point playing for overtime
all right now there's like seconds left
and lamar jackson's just like okay
now i'm gonna be joe montana's three joe
montana moments he goes right down the
[ __ ] field again
gets him within field goal range they
have like a [ __ ] robot
level field goal kicker i mean that
complimentary the man does not miss he
comes out bam right there fred game
[ __ ] over
the announcers are losing their minds
fans are losing their mind
the guy who controls the fake applause
it makes it seem like there's people
there
his [ __ ] fingers are hurting from
everything that was going on there
and they sang everybody's praises
lamar jackson what are you doing here
[ __ ] man oh my baker mayfield
he just chances right back i mean this
guy he really seems like a quarterback
in the future in cleveland oh levi
jackson right going [ __ ] nuts and
that one
not at one moment did they bring up
how [ __ ] horrific the defense was
how to [ __ ] the cleveland bronze how the
[ __ ] after your man
your joe montana goes down and ties up
the game do you let that [ __ ] guy
go by two [ __ ] corners
okay no disrespect to lamar jackson that
was not him
that was the cleveland defense [ __ ]
up
and then the ravens come out they can't
stop baking me he goes right down the
[ __ ] field like it's nothing i don't
know
it was insane it was like watching
tennis
[ __ ] head going back and forth i'm
like what's going on here now it was fun
to watch
i'll tell you that was amazing but i
will tell you but you know at some point
you have to address
either the rules have changed so much
that you can't even cover a receiver
anymore oh that was some [ __ ] defense
i mean that's the second time in like
three weeks i've seen at the end of a
[ __ ] game
that raiders jets game jets got the game
one and then somehow a receiver
is just all alone running down the
[ __ ] field
like some fat drunk who just decided to
come on the field and grab the ball like
who the [ __ ] is this guy
where did that guy come from so i don't
know
it was enjoyable to watch but it was
bizarre to watch
corners getting burned that bad and
nobody even addressed it
they were so busy selling me how amazing
these two quarterbacks were
um you know i guess lamar rolled out so
he bought the time for that guy to do it
but i mean to watch two corners bump
into each other like the [ __ ]
keystone cops and to see a guy
all of a sudden be 15 yards away from
the nearest guy in a brown's uniform and
it's just not addressed it's addressed
for half a second
that was a little frustrating um
but an exciting game nonetheless and uh
let's take a look at the playoff picture
just what you guys need yet another
person
breaking down the nfl all right here we
go here we go
what do we got here let's let's look
let's look at the nfc central
a very exciting division nfc nfl
standings
all right the afc east your buffalo
bills
with a commanding 10-3 lead
10-3 record with the two-game lead over
the miami dolphins great defense
you know we'll see what happens there
but i would have to say that
the bill's got this one patriots six and
seven man
you know this is huge for us we got we
got to win out we have not had a losing
season
season in 20 years the poor jets man oh
and 13. they should be one in 12. how
the [ __ ] do you let that guy get behind
you i'll tell you how you do it you lose
10 other games
and you learn how to lose um afc west
kansas city chiefs 12
and 1 who evidently have the greatest
offense anybody's ever seen which is
amazing to me because
uh i guess they weren't they just
started watching football in the last
five years i have no idea
um their eight is in second place seven
and six
the afc north oh sorry i keep calling to
central
you're steelers 11 and two
cleveland browns nine and four oh man
they needed that one they needed that
victory yeah you son of a [ __ ]
so they're two games back and they
played one more game
i'd say that's a [ __ ] rap the ravens
pull within one
keep their playoff hopes alive the
bengals without joe burrow
two and ten and then the afc south
the division nobody's talking about
everyone was excited about the titans
and then they lost like [ __ ]
three out of four or whatever the [ __ ]
happened to him
and everybody kind of backed off so
we'll see what's going on with them so
here's my pick early not early late
but early for me playoffs playoffs i
like the uh kansas city chiefs to go
back to the super bowl as much as i love
what's going on in buffalo
i think they're a year away um the one
thing that scares me about the chiefs is
everybody's
blowing their offense their defense uh
tends to let up a lot of points against
good teams
i mean it's a nice spread when you look
at it 403-4
281 against but uh i don't know
they they they've they've lit up a
number of like 30
35 points in the game so
i don't know but i just still think with
andy reid
and the three-headed monster on offense
and the way the rules are now
somebody said that the other day it used
to be a good defense beats a good
offense i don't know
i don't know if that's the case anymore
i also don't coach nfl football so what
do i know yet you sit and listen why
because you're in traffic right now
and who saw this coming out of nowhere
the washington football team
six and seven six
and seven you're giants five and eight
see they got one more loss one less so
they've played the same amount of games
so they're only a game out
that's [ __ ] amazing like eight and
eight's gonna win that division
although the lowest the worst record
ever that i have that uh i looked up
to see what it was just watching the nfc
east was
uh the seattle seahawks were seven and
nine one year and made the playoffs
rams nine and four seahawks nine and
four
cardinal seven to six i love that
[ __ ] division
mainly the seahawks and cardinals i love
watching those teams
packers running away with it ten and
three saints are ten and three but drew
brees
is out so where do you go here do you
just go the obvious
do you go the obvious the packers with
ten and three
saints don't have drew brees i don't
know rams got a great head coach who
knows
who knows when they go up to that frozen
tundra and there's nobody in the crowd
to jump into when you when you score a
touchdown are
the packers still doing the lambo leap
these are the questions i have
as we almost are entering one year
of of a [ __ ] lock down here or
whatever the [ __ ] going on here
um yes old billy freckles flew a
helicopter today and i'm getting used to
this because this is my new ride
the cadbury g2 uh
which is just like the robinson r 22
except
uh the fraunch the french people who
built it
they bought an r22 they took the thing
apart
and just analyzed all its strengths and
weaknesses and
i have over 200 hours in an r22
and just seeing the cadbury g2 i can't
say enough about it how amazing it is
every little thing they did on it
made it better it was incredible even
just like
like the uh the carb heat is automatic
the fuel shutoff valve it used to be
right near the carb heat which you had
to
pull so your car your carburetor
wouldn't freeze up
during certain temperatures and the
engine would quit that would be
like the carb heat would be right next
to what you would pull
up to uh you know to kill the engine
with fuel if you had like an engine fire
or something or in the end of a flight
when you're shutting the engine off
i mean there was a guard on it but it
was always it was a little squirrely
and i knew a guy that knew an instructor
that had some kid he told him to pull
the carpet and the kid reached out
he [ __ ] killed the engine and the guy
had to enter an auto fortunately was at
an airport
he had to auto rotate and landed and
they had to stop the instructor from
choking the [ __ ] student
[Music]
so they fixed that um
fully articulated main rotor system um
as opposed to
a semi-articulated so it's it's uh
there's no more you know low g push
overs or anything like that although if
you do nose it over
aggressively enough you could starve the
engine of fuel and the engine could cut
off i know that because i
read about a guy that did that and then
he had to enter an auto
basically just don't be a [ __ ] idiot
and you're gonna be fine
but um there's a little baggage
compartment in the back
it has automatic locking doors so when
you're at an airport where you don't
know anybody you can just click that
thing
and uh it's got the it's it's an amazing
amazing amazing amazing machine and i'm
learning how to fly it and i'm having
the best [ __ ] time
ever it's like a like i said a baby a
star which is basically like what the
cops fly
it's a the smaller two-seater version of
that and uh
it's a lot of fun and i'm psyched that i
have access to it
and i'm going to fly it as much as i can
um which is going to be a lot
to be honest with you because uh i'm
going to go for my instrument now i
passed the test last year you have two
years to take it so
this [ __ ] pandemic really screwed
that all up
screwed that up but i finally got good
times bad times down where
um i can play it up to speed now uh
which i still can't believe but now i'm
i i was just i was riding on the high
heads and i i got a ride over where
i'm on the ride now and i'm trying to
keep the hi-hat going so now i'm up to
like 85 bpm so about 10 bpms away
and i just kind of have the muscle
memory down
now so now it's just a matter of doing
it and it's so
[ __ ] ridiculously exciting so and
i've been working on my french
so as usual what i'm doing is
as i'm doing 90 things at the same time
that are all exciting to me so it keeps
me out of being depressed
with uh you know [ __ ] that i haven't
dealt with
i stay out in front of it by learning
new [ __ ] and i'm really learning that at
some point i am gonna have to slow down
and deal with
whatever makes me such a [ __ ] lunatic
now i don't need the emails well if you
do that you're not gonna be as funny
that's not true
i've learned that that isn't true uh all
it's gonna do is make me be a better
husband and father so
uh i love my wife and my family and i
don't wanna [ __ ] that up so
i need to i need to [ __ ] just sort of
sit in the clouds a little bit with that
[ __ ]
um oh wow look at that he's getting his
instrument rating but in his mind
he's doing the same thing oh jesus bill
um
all right where the hell are we in this
podcast is it time to read a little bit
of advertising here a little bit of ad
reads here um i think it is let's do
some here what do we got here what do we
got here
oh i've also been uh i've been dropping
some pouts i told you i ate an entire
bison
barbecued bison when i was in texas and
i loved every second of it but i put on
some weight so i was already
i had put on weight since halloween and
thanksgiving and all of that [ __ ]
so uh oh billy's become old salad pants
over here
um i can make a great beet salad
um i do an even mixture of uh
red wine vinaigrette with olive oil and
some salt and pepper i toss the lettuce
and that
and then uh then it's just beets
uh goat cheese and some
you know some walnuts that's all i need
i eat that
it fills me up kind of loving it but uh
i've been eating a lot of those lately
so if you guys got some good recipes for
some healthy salads
i'd like to have like five and for you
people who want to start eating salads
it's all about the prep okay
so what i would do is you buy a head of
whatever kind of lettuce you want
romaine i like the butter
lettuce uh i don't mind romaine whatever
you iceberg whatever you want what i
would suggest
is whatever you get cut it all up dice
it all up
and then you know rinse it off put it in
your salad spinner
like sue murphy on ephesus family okay
and then all of it is ready to go okay
because that cleaning out the salad
spinner is a pain in the [ __ ] ass
so you got the whole head of lettuce is
ready to go if you get your beets
chop those [ __ ] and peel those
[ __ ] i i do it underneath the plastic
bag so because that's
that red [ __ ] just gets all over the
cutting board
um dice those [ __ ] up so those things
are just ready to go so it's almost like
you know when you go into those those
places the fast food place salad place
they have all
this stuff all prepped if you have that
ready to go you can just go in
and just bing bang boom put the thing
together throw a little
balsamic vinaigrette whatever you want
in there
it prevents you from eating bad because
eating bad is easy
you just go in you open a bag or
something and it's ready to go and you
just start stuffing your face in this
this sort of fruitless chase
of not being hungry you're sort of just
tricking your body into feeling like
it's not hungry but then
after a while it sifts through
everything that you put in
to your stomach like a storage shed and
then it realizes that it was just a
bunch of [ __ ] and it didn't get any
nutrients and then you're hungry again
so then you eat more of this [ __ ] that's
how you become a fat [ __ ]
um i'm speaking from experience so
um i got a great um
a great beet salad recipe and um
i would like some more i would i would
definitely like some more just to kind
of break it up
and uh because they really fill you up
and you just [ __ ] drop weight like a
champ you [ __ ] start eating salads
and going for walks
i mean your neighbors will think you got
a disease or something
um oh me and my wife had such a stupid
fight last night
and this is this is why i love my wife
and why
we've been able to to be together for so
long as we had this dumbass fight
um because i i don't want to get into it
it was just a
stupid fight and we went to bed pissed
at each other
and then this morning
you know we woke up or whatever
and i didn't say anything to her she
didn't say anything to me and then i was
brushing my teeth and she was brushing
her teeth
and she just goes good morning and i go
morning
and i looked at her and she looked at me
and we both just started laughing
and that was that was it
over um which i think is pretty cool
although a therapist would probably be
like but did you talk about
why you thought shut up
all right mark what am i mac weldon
three reads today mack weldon
uh you know when it comes to holiday
gifting for guys
i'll be the first to admit that it's not
necessarily my strong suit now i don't
understand why that they would just
[ __ ] write that [ __ ]
man they took a lot of liberties there
i'll be the first to why do i have to go
first
you think i don't know how to rap i just
don't like doing it but now thanks to
mack weldon it's super easy
and simple to find something great no
matter which guy you're shopping for
um i'll be the first to admit that it's
not necessarily my strong suit
oh finding a gift for guys
well just [ __ ] buy him a [ __ ] rack
of lamb
throw a bow on it wait no matter which
guys you're shopping for
okay whether it's mac weldon's warm knit
tops undershirts or sunday lounge pants
mac weldon has men's basics that are
guaranteed to keep everyone on your
list okay ladies if you're trying to
shop for your men
gay guys closeted gay guys
this is this is for you right here or if
you got a brother or something like that
you know he likes lounging
i guess this is for heterosexual people
too bill why do you have to label it
because that's what i do
all right what makes max weldon the
perfect gift for guys
talk about the items you've received and
why you're like oh [ __ ] you know what i
did get a pair of their pants and they
were [ __ ] amazing
they were amazing these little slacks
sort of sweatpants they had pockets
there was places to put things and you
just
you know the junk felt good all right
there let's get to it how did your junk
feel in those pants fell it felt
nestled nestled in there right everybody
was happy
the twins and the [ __ ] meat hammer
sorry all right men's essentials socks
shirts hoodies underwear polos or
active shorts mac welton promises
comfort and con and consistent fit
versatility they look great they feel
great from working out going out going
to work or on a date
mac weldon is for everyday life well the
ones that i got looked like that you
could work out in them go out
and go to work i don't know if you were
on a date unless you got dating down and
you just do the cup of coffee in the
afternoon which is the way to [ __ ] go
it's cheap you get to know the person
okay you're looking for a relationship
okay i'm not taking out your wine and
dying yours the diceman says you whiner
your diner
you throw a couple of burgers down her
trout
um technology wide range of customized
fabrics that can keep
up with your keep up with you no matter
what the day looks like
18-hour silver air knit
x dry knit warm knit well
weld in blue totally free loyalty
program i don't even what i'm reading
here this sounds like code
level one gets you okay here's the
loyalty program level one
get you free shipping for life once you
reach level two by spending 200 bucks
you get 20 off every order for the next
year oh they're reeling you in
how do you pass up these deals guarantee
mac
weldon wants you to be comfortable so if
you don't like your first pair of
underwears
you can keep them and they'll still
refund you no questions asked
thank god they don't come you don't ship
them back all right i got nervous there
uh when the gift giving reseason well
win the gift giving season and get
twenty percent off your first order
visit mack weldon m-a-c-k
w-e-l-d-o-n a c k
w e l d o n mack weldon dot com
slash bur b u r r and enter the promo
code bur
that's macweldon.com promo code burr for
off mac weldon reinventing men's basics
yeah seriously if you get these this
closed for any guy he's going to be
psyched they're comfortable
they're easy to put on i mean everything
i've got you don't have to iron
it's kind of the [ __ ] um all right here
we go candid company
you know all the things we'd love to do
for ourselves but haven't done for
whatever reason
well if you've always wanted to
straighten your teeth
and have a better smile stop putting it
off thanks to
candid straightening your teeth uh is
sorry thanks to candid straightening
your teeth is simpler easier
and more comfortable than ever there's
no [ __ ] reason for you not to have
straight teeth these days
all right you listening to me that
certain country that always gets made
fun of for crooked teeth
candid clear aligners are comfortable
removable
and practically invisible unlike wire
braces
uh so you can transform your smile
without anyone noticing plus your
treatment is prescribed
and monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
and it's all done from the comfort and
convenience of your own home
candid only works with orthodontics
never general dentists like other
companies you don't want that you want
the pros the orthodontist plus
your supervising orthodontist will be
with you every step of the way
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
so you never have to wonder who uh how
you're doing you'll always know
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then and it costs
thousands less than braces start
straightening your teeth today
right now all listeners can save 75
on candid starter kit go to candidco.com
and use the code burr that's candid
c-a-n-d-i-d-c-o-dot-com
code bur take advantage of this limited
time offer to save 75
dollars on your first on your starter
kit candidco.com
code bur all right and lastly but
certainly not leastly everybody
certainly not leastly it's hello fresh
oh hello fresh it's so good to see
you hello fresh delivers fresh
high quality pre-portioned ingredients
so you can make meals
that are delicious and nutritious
talking about
dropping weight here you go over 90 of
the ingredients are sourced directly
from growers to ensure peak flavor and
ripeness
hellofresh is the first global carbon
neutral meal
kit company okay so it's it's it's fresh
high level high grade food whatever you
say and
it doesn't uh you know it's not a bunch
of plastic containers
polluting the environment great value
say 40
when you use hellofresh versus shopping
at the grocery store
by skipping the grocery store and using
hellofresh you're reducing your your
food waste
by at least 25
that's because you'll eat it all up
tremendous easily easily
change your delivery days or meal plan
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need
uh right on the app so if you're going
away on vacation like me
to do a little stand-up and you can eat
half a [ __ ] bison
barbecued in texas you can just go to
the app and be like okay
i'm gonna work on being a fat [ __ ] for
the next 10 days i'll talk to you
afterwards and hello fresh will be like
we understand
keep your fridge stocked by adding extra
meals or additional proteins quick meals
like breakfast on the go
or their 10-minute lunches even desserts
to satisfy that sweet tooth hello fresh
has committed
uh is committed to donating to those in
need so far in 2020
they've donated 3.5 million meals isn't
that great all these poor americans
living in tent cities here
we should be helping them out hellofresh
offers convenient no content delivery to
your doorstep for easy home cooking
with the family go to hellofresh.com 80
and use the code
80 to get 80 off including free shipping
that's hellofresh.com uh slash
80 bur code 80 80 burr for 80
off and free shipping all right
everybody
that is the podcast enjoy your football
this weekend oh by the way i didn't even
say how much i called that [ __ ] lsu
game
did i call it i went on twitter and i
called it and everybody was [ __ ]
sitting there going i can't believe that
guy threw that shoe
everybody couldn't believe it but no
everybody had no problem with the
florida gators going forward on fourth
and goal
five minutes into the [ __ ] game i
know you guys are getting and not
getting it
i know you guys are getting sick of this
all right but i'm i i feel like
i'm making a point that needs to be
listened to because in my head
it all makes sense everything that i say
makes sense because i'm the one saying
it all right
see that i'm just like you um all right
shout out to flat earthers and people
who don't believe in the virus
you know you're also fellow americans i
still love you i don't understand you
but i support your right to go on the
internet with no scientific background
whatsoever
and just look up [ __ ] that agrees with
you all right because that's what i do
okay um all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great weekend you
[ __ ]
and i'll see you on mondays
oh by the way enjoy the music and uh
there'll be a bonus half hour
uh episode from a it's a greatest hits
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast goodbye
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday december 17 2012.
um i am emotionally exhausted
from watching that patriots san
francisco game
uh last night how insane was that game
unbelievable um unfortunately it was
exactly what i thought
although the comeback i was amazed by
that but i i've i've
i've gotten so much [ __ ] from a couple
friends of mine who are patriots fans
because they feel like i'm not a
patriots fan anymore because i keep
talking about
how bad our defense is and uh they're
one of those people who like you know
they like dress like drew bledsoe when
they watch the game you know those
people whether they're such
[ __ ] fans that no matter what's going
on you you can never say anything
what they deem is like negative rather
than constructive criticism but you know
i feel vindicated because last week when
we beat the texans they were sitting
there going you see
look at that you know there's your
defense
what do you got to say now you read edit
cut
yeah i didn't think so get dixon
right i've been telling the whole
[ __ ] time that the afc is weak
all right it's [ __ ] weak the nfc has
been far
superior to the afc for [ __ ] years
all right but the thing is you got brady
and belichick
and a little bit of luck and that's how
we got to the [ __ ] super bowl last
year we still almost won
but that doesn't change the fact that
our defense
sucks all right
oh we do good against the mediocre teams
and the so-called good teams in the afc
but i'm telling you right now
we'll be lucky if we get by the broncos
okay you let up [ __ ]
40-something points to a second-year
quarterback i can't help you
why is my voice cracking because i've
been screaming at the [ __ ] tv for
three hours watching the damn thing
um yeah if the 49ers actually had a
quarterback they would have scored like
you know a more experienced quarterback
i'm not [ __ ] on their uh
their guy there with the soul patch
whatever the [ __ ] his name is at a boise
state who could have played baseball he
uh but he had one [ __ ] shot he took
the
how many [ __ ] times can you tell that
story um
i mean he missed like two guys who will
have like three steps on our safety
i don't know [ __ ] brutal but i knew
it was gonna happen
i knew it was gonna happen you know what
i mean i mean i hate to say it but if
you know if the 49ers had aaron rodgers
uh drew brees a [ __ ] you know eli
manning you know
it's we can't compete with that kills me
kills me i don't know what the [ __ ] we
have to do but
you know we're all right we're all right
in the box as they say
but i swear to god our [ __ ] past
defense stinks
i don't i don't you know it just
it was you know it was enjoyable
watching the 49ers celebrating and
stomping around and doing that because
they're doing their job
all that dumb [ __ ] that every [ __ ]
athlete does now
you know you [ __ ] get a layup for two
points and then you go
scare children in the front row like
like you this
like you're actually in 300 you know
why don't you just [ __ ] bend over and
blow yourself at that point
i really enjoyed watching the 49ers do
that and then get that deer in their
headlights look as brady
calmly just just dismantled their
[ __ ] awesome defense
and tied it up and scored like 34 points
in like basically a quarter
i did enjoy 31 whatever the [ __ ] it was
i did enjoy that watching them have to
stand down and actually having
seeing that glazed over look oh and now
the phone rings
now the [ __ ] phone rings could
anything else be going on with this
podcast
just seeing that glazed overlook on jim
harbaugh's face
was enjoyable but i [ __ ] loved that
guy and i loved the uh
the fake punt call in the for first
quarter
on your own 40 was that was always
awesome
i i had to respect it it's like this guy
is going for the jugular
but i mean those guys honestly could
have been up like 21-0 after like six
minutes in the game
um yeah so there you go
there's a great nice big bucket of ice
water
to the face of delusional patriots fans
that's
that's what it is that's where our
defense is against
um the elite teams you know sucks
i'm not happy about it and um
yeah i'm not [ __ ] happy about it i
just wish we could we could
oh for [ __ ] sakes with your [ __ ]
you know what i hate about this
[ __ ] stupid phone besides everything
so you have the [ __ ] thing on mute it
still makes noise
like like i get important phone calls
right clio what am i the president
does it really need to do that even when
you [ __ ] put it on on silent mode
it still vibrates i guess i could just
shut the thing off right
i never i never even thought to do that
that's great i worked that out oh yeah
of course my password doesn't work on
the [ __ ] computer
this is just going to be one of these
days you know i know it's going to be
one of these days is i took my dog out
for a walk
and she took a [ __ ] and unlike rapaport
i went to pick the [ __ ] thing up
right and i had my headphones on and as
i bent over to do it my headphones fell
down and almost landed in the pile of
dog [ __ ]
and uh rather than laughing it off
like somebody with rosy cheeks would um
i'm a cynical bastard so i took that as
an omen
on how this day was gonna be and uh it's
lived up that way
i had a bowl of cereal this morning i
almost [ __ ] died
and you know what's funny is the lovely
nia was
literally maybe seven feet away in the
other room
and never checked on me
could give a [ __ ] you know you know what
that is
it's like we've been together when
you've been with somebody as long as i
have
they just it's not like they want you to
die
it's a combination of two things they
they
they just tune you out so i could have
been in there
talking to her about how you know my
headphones almost fell into the dog [ __ ]
this morning or
i could have been almost choking to
death either way she doesn't even hear
it
and then like subconsciously it's not
that they want you to die
but they not fatally but if you could
die for like three hours
you know i i don't think that they would
be upset
just sort of you know drag you over and
put you behind the couch
and just you know fantasize about being
single again for like three hours and
then you you know you wake up
like in one of those those movies with
kiefer sutherland what was that movie
called
shockers wasn't clockers that was spike
lee i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] it was
anyways this is what happened i was
eating uh
i corn chex i'm a big fan of the chex
family
all right this isn't some sort of subtle
advertising i'm trying to put in here
okay
this is this is coming from my heart not
my wallet all right i like to check
cereals i'm not into rice chex
that has nothing to do with world war ii
or vietnam okay i just don't like the
taste of them
okay i'm not coming at you with some red
state [ __ ] like i ain't eating nothing
that got [ __ ] rice in it after what
happened over there
in uh uh the dmz i'm not coming at you
like that
i just don't like the taste of that one
i either go corn checks or i go wheat
chicks
so here's the yeah you know what i
noticed the other day is this this
morning when as i was almost choking to
death on my cereal was
all cereal is kind of the same color you
notice that
it's all sort of [ __ ] just different
kind of browns
isn't that weird isn't that weird that
that would go through my head as i'm
almost
dying choking that [ __ ]
bad 80s comedian analogy went through my
head
that would that might have been my last
thought
you know or like it's like a topic you'd
hear on like npr
all things considered today we discuss
the different shades of brown and
breakfast cereals
i don't care if you're eating rice chex
corn chex
wheat chex rice krispies or corn flakes
the all too familiar off color band-aid
brown on all things considered
um yeah we can listen to npr nia listens
to that [ __ ] she's such a [ __ ] nerd
and she always has it on and i'm
i and you know i don't know there's
really no good radio stations out here
as far as like playing music
out here in la i don't know why
i don't know what i don't know what goes
on out here but evidently
uh these the two bands that they play
they play them like it's still 19 the
early 90s
they play ice cube all the time
badam when you come to my town badam
like
like i don't know why they play it like
they play it enough
like you think he he died or something
you know and then uh and then they also
play the uh
who are those guys
whatever the [ __ ] they are pretty fly
for a white guy they play them all the
[ __ ] time
you know like everybody's still walking
around in flannels going hey have you
heard the new pearl jam
man um anyways
so here's the story i basically go to
get my [ __ ] box of corn checks
i pick up the box immediately i notice
it's pretty light you know pour it in
get a full bowl and there's like an
eighth of a box left now i could be a
douche and put the box back
and give nia false hope oh i want a box
you know i want a bowl of cereal you
know and then she grabs the box and she
fills the lightness
then that panic comes in you start to
sweat like oh [ __ ]
you start pouring it out come on man
keep going and there's only an eighth of
a bowl left
you know the douche puts that back in
the cupboard
the gentleman the refined individual
like myself
you just say all right i'm gonna have a
little more cereal than i usually have
so that's what i did
all right i started eating the [ __ ]
cereal and i'm wolfing it down because i
know the podcast is a little bit late
and i'm going to get a bunch of [ __ ]
on twitter right so
i get about halfway done with my bowl i
take the box of cereal and i pour that
last eighth in you know the deal
the last part of the box that's the most
dangerous part of the box
you know you got half it's half of its
cereal and the rest of it's all [ __ ]
powdered so all the powder goes on my
on the top of the cereal i start eating
the [ __ ] and i'm doing that you know
eating so fast
you're eating and inhaling through your
[ __ ] pie hole
doing that [ __ ] and i had a half a spoon
of powder the other half was the cereal
and i inhaled the [ __ ] and
my my throat just closed off
and i thought i was gonna i thought at
the very least i was gonna pass out to
the point i was i was debating
as i'm coughing and hacking away and nia
is completely ignoring me
um i'm sitting this pounding i'm
thinking should i make them loud noise
in the kitchen
or should i run to you know five steps
to the bedroom but then i'm thinking
well that like take up too much oxygen
and um i basically was choking on this
[ __ ] for three straight minutes and nia
didn't
move a [ __ ] muscle didn't move a
goddamn muscle
and when i finally i finally uh realized
i was going to live
i was so pissed at her that you know you
know after you get done choking like
your voice is like it's like turned down
to one
so you're trying to talk it's like you
know thanks for helping you know that
type of [ __ ]
i basically said sarcastically thanks
for helping in the i was just choking
for three minutes voice and all i get
for neo is like
oh i'm sorry are you okay
you know is that any way to start the
[ __ ] day
i don't think is is that was that even
funny was that even remotely
amusing to you i i don't know
i almost died this morning i don't care
if i'm funny or not
cleo um
all right let's do let's do a little
advertising here and then i'm going to
talk to you about this 30 for 30 i watch
called broke
all right um where are we oh we got a
new we got new advertising this week
everybody cascade studios
cascade studios on santa monica
boulevard
out here in los angeles we got a local
ad here
um this is a rehearsal studio um
if you're in a band basically and you
need a rehearsal space cascade studios
is the number one place here
in uh los angeles this is when i go down
i play drums and i try to
pull off that bottom stuff trying to get
my foot as fast as his this is where i
go i go to cascade studios 6611 santa
monica boulevard
if you want to go down there with your
whole band they got a five piece drum
kit in every room with high hats
two guitar ramps bass amp pa system with
three mics
symbol rental is only five bucks um
or if you're just a drummer like myself
and you want to go down there with your
ipod
and beat the hell out of a kit and have
a great time he charges you 15 bucks for
an hour
i highly recommend it um i go down there
all the time
if you go down ask for joe tell him the
monday morning podcast sent you
and as always everybody it's stamps.com
with the holidays almost here you don't
have time to go to the post office
there's traffic there's parking there's
somebody in front of you is gonna have
like 90 boxes that they're sending out
to all their grandkids
you know as they take out the changed
person their hand is shaking right
it's going to be packed with everyone
mailing out holiday gifts is what i'm
trying to say and packages
so what do i do i use stamps.com instead
stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle
of going to the post office during the
busy holiday season
everything you would do at the post
office you can do right from your desk
or your apartment wherever the hell
you're at um buy and print official us
postage using your own computer and
printer
print postage for any letter or package
the instant you need it
then the mailman comes and picks it up
it's so easy and convenient you don't
have to go down to the post office and
deal with everything that i just
described
i use stamps.com to send out all the
merch from my shows
you should do it too well i guess you
shouldn't unless you're doing a show
but whatever if you got all these
christmas gifts
that's the way to send it out stamps.com
right now get this special offer when
you use my last name bur
b-u-r-r for a no-risk trial plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars free postage they're
giving you 55
during the holiday season don't wait go
to stamps.com right now before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the page
and type in burr b-u-r-r dot com
enter bur b-u-r-r alrighty
back to the podcast so i was watching um
i was watching one of those 30-30s
um and they did this whole thing on on
athletes going broke it was really bad
there's a ton of people who've gone
broke most of them didn't want to do the
documentary
like why would you you know what i mean
hey you want to talk about how you
completely [ __ ] blew it no i don't
i don't and i resent the fact at the end
of your documentary you're going to be
running a list with my name on it
you know that's what they had at the end
of it but um
i was watching it and i felt bad for
people but after a while it was just the
same
[ __ ] story over and over again
and it's as much as i want to say that
if i was 21 years old and you gave me a
million dollars
that i would probably [ __ ] it up too i
i just don't think i would you know
i had these guys you know i i got a
check for 55 000
and i saw a hummer i had to get it talk
the guy down to 49 thousand dollars
and it's like if you just got to check
for 55 [ __ ] grand
after paying all the people in your life
your agent whoever else you got
where else is taking it your lawyer
whoever else takes a chunk out of that
check
whatever's left out of that the
government's going to come in and take a
40 where if you get a check for 55 grand
i mean what do you got left
20 grand he just went out and bought a
50 000 hummer
i don't know but anyways the point i
wanted to make was at the end of it
after showing all these people going
through this hell they have this guy
there who's supposed to be
evidently some sort of uh financial
advisor
and in the end they were talking about
lebron james going he is going to be
he has a potential to be other than
tiger woods
pre-divorce um
a billionaire athlete and they like how
exciting is that
and they go what what would your advice
be to this to lebron james
on how to hang on to his billion dollars
and the guy goes
he goes don't blow it keep it simple
count your money that's what he said
it might have been the dumbest thing i
ever heard and i immediately
i had no sympathy for anybody
in the [ __ ] documentary it's just
like
even like why is this guy on this
document who the [ __ ] is that guy
that's a guy who manages money that's
hey i got a billion dollars
how do i hold on to this where should i
invest it
what do i do what advice do you got for
me
well it's simple don't blow it keep it
simple
count your money all right thanks a lot
i'll be i'm out of here
[ __ ] ridiculous it was basically it
was an hour and a half of listening to
morons telling you what the [ __ ] they
bought with all their money and i i
don't know
i felt bad but there was another part
there was just one guy that i really
felt bad for
because it was
the hurt that he had you know
like andre ryzen was on the thing and
he's sitting there in his suit with
sunglasses
on mirrored sunglasses doing the
interview and just right there it's like
yeah dude
i'd give you another million if i had it
if i gave it to you
you'd [ __ ] that up why because
you're sitting here in a shiny suit with
[ __ ] sunglasses on
looking like michael jackson at the
award show right
so anyways the one guy who actually
really bothered me was there's
if you ever watch it it's 30 for 30
broke
there's a guy who's sitting there and
he's just
ever so slightly leaned to one side
and just the the pain
in his voice he's just
just sitting there going uh i made uh
75 million dollars in my career and i
add me a mercedes
got a hummer
got me a boat he's just sitting there
looking down on his knee like playing
with his pant leg
i had a jet ski and
[Music]
and you just i had to look away it was
[ __ ]
brutal but the rest of it was just a
bunch of knuckleheads
you know i felt bad for bernie kozar too
because bernie kozar uh you know
i don't know it seemed like his dad took
his money i don't know what the [ __ ] it
was it was
it's it's a really it's a it's a great
all the 30 for 30s are awesome this one
is awesome
but they just should have had a couple
of
they did you know something that's not
true because they had like four or five
guys
there was only two people who really
came off like morons
but they were just so they were such
morons that i felt it tainted the whole
thing
ugh then this might have been the
dumbest thing i ever heard
what is your advice don't blow it keep
it simple
count your money
all right i'm sorry was it was that even
remotely [ __ ] interesting
i love watching those 30 for 30s i got
to watch the bo jackson one
um there was just something about that
like you know for as
much as they showed the amount of people
that went broke there's been so many
more people in the league
that didn't go broke so really weren't
you just showing
a select group of morons
you know who were going out and buying a
corvette and sticking a [ __ ] hot tub
in the back of it
you know living week to week on
paychecks i mean i just don't think that
most people are doing that
i would really think that if if i was
barely on the team
i would be saving every dime i know i
would
i've done that in this business i've
never [ __ ]
you know it's coming if you're in any
sort of entertainment
you know it's coming and the day it's
coming
is the day you think that you're good
and that you made it that's when
somebody comes in with the hood on
and the sickle and they just [ __ ]
chop you in half and then that's it
and then you're that guy on tv [ __ ]
lean into women that's why that guy was
leaned to one side they had to twist his
torso back onto some fake legs
as he sat there going like i i got me a
cabin
bought a mountain ah
you know you'd think that if you had 75
million dollars that you couldn't have
you know that [ __ ] goes
and and when it when it goes uh
there's nobody around um
anyways i got to watch it a few more
times i feel like there's com there's
some sort of comedy in there
i just don't know if i got to it today
uh
anyways i've been drinking like a
[ __ ] madman lately i really have to
stop
i just keep going to these these friggin
uh christmas parties
you know and they got booze there
so yeah you know something maybe that if
i got like a zillion dollars maybe that
that that's what i would have would have
done
would have gone out and become a
complete freaking booze bag
now what the [ __ ] did i do with my notes
here
oh for christ's sake i swear to god this
is just it's not my day
it's not here it's not there it's not
here it's not there what the [ __ ] is it
there it is you know what let's read a
question here my brain is
suffering from lack of oxygen here let's
just read a question
college duet hey man i'll keep this
question
short i got my eye on this broad she
heard me playing music
in the dorms knocked on my door i
invited her in and we talked for a bit
jesus christ dude
i don't think you need any advice that
sounds like you're already there
she just heard your talent and came
knocking on your door what more does she
have to do
you know pull up her dress and back her
way in
anyways oh she said she wants to do
duets together
my fault i didn't realize she was also
in the business oh
jesus um
anyway second time i wasn't playing
music but she knocked on the door and
started talking about duets again
not sure if she wanted to play then or
what but i was busy studying
so i invited her in again and we talked
yet again dude you're only going to get
so many at bats where it's going to be
weird
if you finally [ __ ] make a move all
right
what are you doing i i this is where did
that come from
um anyways i figure i'll invite her down
uh i have a single dorm with her and
instrument
once the work load didn't really sound
good
what i figure i'll invite her down i
have a single dorm with her instrument
once the workload
after holidays dies down and just kiss
her
and see what happens oh this is just a
band geek
all right what are you doing hey come on
over and and bring your
your bassoon and then she's going to
walk in you're just going to kiss her
please tell me there's going to be some
sort of preamble of making her laugh or
something at least going to try to light
a candle
anyways he says how does that sound any
advice i've had almost no interaction
with her before
or after this by the way uh okay
he goes love the podcast keep it up
you're a great guy just kidding [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
all right um
what what do you want to do with her you
just want a banger if you just want a
banger what you have to do is just
you have to stop acting like a gentleman
and i don't mean that in some sort of
gropey
disgusting manner what i mean is you
have to
you have to not just say
this [ __ ] you're thinking all right
just say the [ __ ] you're thinking and
say what you want to do
all right if it's one of those but if
this girl but if the girl is like
uh i don't know she's more
walled off i don't know what the [ __ ]
word is i think that brain cell died
when i inhaled the power
powder this morning um she's more walled
off
that i don't know she's like a nerd i
don't know what to tell you
i never was able to interact
with female nerds beyond just talking to
them because they were just so [ __ ]
i don't like everything was like awkward
so and then after that i was just like
you know what
i could literally rub one out faster
than it's gonna take
for me to figure out just how to get her
glasses off
so yeah dude just invite her down
[ __ ] her instrument you know get the
music out of it
and just say hey i'm you want to come
down i'm watching a movie tonight just
get her over there
all right i don't know i don't know
where you've gone with the conversation
so far
if it's gonna seem weird if all of a
sudden you're sitting there and you're
hugh hefner rope
but that's the vibe i would have tried
to bring if you just want a banger
that's what i would do if you want if
you want to date this girl
then i'd take her out but if you just
want a banger you you
you have to start acting like a [ __ ]
um
crass individual sooner rather than
later
you know you know what's a good way to
kind of
bring it into the sex thing is if you're
watching tv and just start talking about
some [ __ ] girl on the tv
how hot you think she is and blah blah
blah hopefully that'll spin her around
and be like why what do you find
attractive
in a woman and then you just [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah well like take a
look at you you kind of got your [ __ ]
titties there
sitting in my phone right and then
you're in
right does that work i hope it works for
you sir
because i think you are a great guy
you're a great guy because you
you're sitting in the dorm and you're
you're practicing your [ __ ] piccolo
um all right next one
actually you know what that reminds me
of a long time ago
long time ago i went to this girl's dorm
and she wanted me to and i wanted to and
i didn't know how to [ __ ] bridge that
gap and we sat on her [ __ ]
single bed for like till my ass fell
asleep and i finally ended up just i
just finally just said i have to just
get out of here
i don't know how to you know what i mean
i i don't i don't know how to [ __ ]
crack the safe
so i should have been a little more
empathetic god i was pathetic
i was i was [ __ ] pathetic
not saying i'm i mean i think that's
been a through line in my life just
being pathetic but
it's sort of morphed you know
every time i feel like oh you know hey
kind of got that settled then this a new
thing
you know like say podcasting
i feel like this is a pretty pathetic
attempt this week don't you
well go [ __ ] yourself hit the stop
button i don't give a [ __ ]
i really don't that's one of the great
things about this this podcasting world
is you really don't have to give a [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is the man great thing
there it is hey everybody this holiday
season
this holiday season think the man great
what is the man great you ask
they're made of 100 they're 100 made in
america cast iron grilling grates
that are revolutionizing the way people
grill
um named one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine now
come on
men's health magazine you know they're
trying to teach guys how to be
guys a guy grilling it doesn't get any
more manlier than that and it was named
one of 2012's best grilling accessories
i don't know what else you need to know
man greats are the perfect gift this
holiday season click on the man great
banner
on billboard.com on the podcast page for
their 1999 holiday special this is a
twenty dollar gift
that i'm telling you it's going to
change your life this is such a great
gift to get your dad
okay if your dad's a man and he grills
he's not upstairs eating bok choy you
know
your dad goes out and he shoots a
pheasant ties it to the
uh the rear view mirror and drives home
with it letting the blood drip down on
the radio this is what you want you want
the man great system get it for him
again it's the man that's the man great
grill enhancement system
order today at billboard.com click on
the podcast page
and uh and get yourself one today for
only 19.99 the holiday special
all righty okay there you go
the [ __ ] that reminded me of something
in the middle there
the hell was i gonna talk about
oh i know you know what i was gonna make
uh i was gonna try to make this
shepherd's pie this week every once in a
while i get like really into cooking
it's usually when i have a down time in
this business and this time of year i
always take uh
i always take some time off you know i
don't like working over the holidays
i did enough of those [ __ ] awful uh
new year's eve gigs
you know you're in some god forsaken
[ __ ] strip mall
in the middle of nowhere you're all by
yourself
you go on stage you got like a 50 50
chance that they already handed out the
[ __ ] noisemakers
you're standing up there eating your
balls and then they make you do the
countdown stop your act
did i talk about this last week i feel
like i already did i'll fast forward
through this [ __ ] and then you got to
somehow
then they want you to continue your act
after the countdown it's the worst
[ __ ] thing ever
and everybody's hugging and kissing and
that type of [ __ ] you're standing up
there by yourself like the absolute
you know cliched entertainer
you know sitting there crying in your
tuxedo
so anyway so i usually i take this time
of year off and i uh i start
i always get i get into cooking cleo
stop staring at me
come here stop staring at me so anyways
um i'm a big mario batali fan right
so i made these braised short ribs
that were the [ __ ] [ __ ] i went out
and got myself a dutch oven
you know which because of that joke has
really been ruined there's no way to
[ __ ] say dutch oven
and cooking without somebody thinking
about somebody farting under the
blankets and pulling it over your face
but i made these braised short ribs that
have been the [ __ ] but nia's on a
[ __ ] diet so she's not eating any of
them so i ate like half a pig myself
and i don't think my belly has ever been
rounder or whiter
i have like one of those toddler
stomachs you know those little
beer bellies that they have you know
what i'm talking about cleo
cleo you want to finish the rest of this
podcast
do you well then get off me
the [ __ ] dog is so goddamn needy um
all right let's continue on here with
the questions for this week
if i can find it my computer of course i
can't
because this is just how my day's been
working i should have known as you know
i should have gone right back to bed
the [ __ ] the second
my headphones almost fell in dog [ __ ]
isn't that isn't that like a sign
that you should end the [ __ ] podcast
33 minutes in this is brutal
brutal all right doucheboss dear bill
first i want to say
uh um i have all the episodes of
uninform you did with the teen idol
sensation on my phone and listen to them
every day
but on to my dilemma i'm 18 and work at
the finish line
at the mall and my boss is a complete
dick
of course he is because he's man
managing a finish line at the mall
you're 18 you got your whole life ahead
of you he probably [ __ ] married the
wrong person
he's starting to go bald he's standing
there wearing that referee uniform
going hey what did i tell you about the
chuck taylors you know i thought i told
you to [ __ ] stalk them up in the back
whatever the hell they say don't you
just want to choke him with his whistle
do they make you wear whistles there or
is that athlete's foot or is that the
foot locker
i don't know actually you know something
i have like the the
worst collection of dirty white boys
sneakers you're ever going to see in
your life
every time i look at my sneaker
collection i picture
you know keith robinson or patrice
if he was still alive god damn it um
just trashing me you know what's funny
about how much i miss patrice is the
amount of times
is when i i i miss that guy
how the [ __ ] do i tell the story without
[ __ ] out outing somebody
somebody told gave a [ __ ] speech you
know or whatever went on some rant about
the state of comedy and everybody
thought it was [ __ ] amazing it was
just one of those times where i wish
patrice was in the room
when this person was [ __ ] pro you
know was was talking about it
that's when i missed that dude the
[ __ ] most i missed him then i missed
him when
um penn state that sandusky guy
when he did when he gave the [ __ ]
interview
you know that interview when he i think
he was talking to bob costas and they
were going do you
uh do you like little boys and he was
like
do i like little boys i mean i
enjoy their company and you know
somebody says do you like little boys
there's one [ __ ] answer no
no i don't okay
and [ __ ] you for asking me that and this
guy's sitting there like you know
like trying to work out the math in his
head and as
i as creepy as it was to watch that when
i
watched it i was actually laughing
thinking of patrice watching it laughing
hysterically
and how he would somehow get 25 minutes
of material just out of that guy
trying to figure out how to answer that
that question i swear to god like i
don't know
we got this benefit coming up for him
and as just putting the thing together
it's just like going through him dying
all over again it's been [ __ ] brutal
but good and a good positive things
because everybody bought up the tickets
but it's just been like this [ __ ]
uh the finality of it it's just
something like on that like i even
talked to all my buddies like we bring
him up like he's still around
and we'll talk about him like he's still
around for five minutes before you just
start looking at the ground it's just
[ __ ] awful
i really i really do not wish that you
know i don't know why you would but and
it's not even
worth even stating but i really don't
wish this on [ __ ] anybody because uh
it's really just something when i'm 80
well
if i'm lucky enough you know the way
i've been drinking lately
let's just be a little more conservative
i'm 68.
[Laughter]
it's just something that's still just
going to be i've just i'm coming to an
acceptance that it's going to be as
sad when i'm that age as it is right now
you know so i figured i'd talk about
that to add to the already
not hilarious podcast that i'm doing
this week i'd add to the uh losing a
close friend
[ __ ] vibe you know
who's getting who it really wasn't a
funny [ __ ] week out in the world
uh all right doucheboss where are we
here um
at the finish line he is one of those
guys who okay his boss is a complete
dick all right he says
uh he's one of those guys who got
bullied all through high school
and now actually has some control and
takes it out on me
and and the other employees how did you
figure that out is that you just like
psychologically breaking the guy down
do i have to tell you something there's
nothing worse
than watching somebody uh
abuse their position of power however
however small it is
you know like this guy right here has no
right getting mad at like an athlete who
goes around being a dick because it's
like dude you're doing the exact same
thing you just can't run a 440.
but your your head space is the exact
same place
as some you know egomaniac [ __ ]
athlete you just you just suck at sports
so you sell the gear two people to go
play sports
anyways he says he even steals out of
the register at work
and holds the special release shoes for
him and his friends
he's 30 years old and tries to [ __ ] the
16s and 17 year olds who work there
oh my god this guy is a character right
out of the movies
you know i worked with a guy like this i
used to work in a restaurant a long time
ago
sorry i'm trying to get the czech cereal
out of my throat
um i used to work with this this guy and
basically like
four or five of these guys bought into a
restaurant
and and the one guy who's going to be
there every day
who's always the guy who ends up
stealing the silent partners always get
[ __ ]
his his buy-in was he had all the the
equipment for the kitchen
so he he he i don't know he had some
other failed restaurant he got all the
equipment
and uh but anyways this guy was a
cokehead he used to steal out of the
register
he used to [ __ ] uh try to bang the uh
not the maitre d the [ __ ] uh major
dias whatever the [ __ ] chick who sets
you down the hot one
you know who dresses classy that skirt
[ __ ] going right over her shapely ass
yeah he used to try to [ __ ] bang them
all the goddamn time and when they
wouldn't give it up
they'd get fired and then he'd be
bringing a new one
if that one ended up banging him then
she stuck around was brutal
so anyways he goes uh he harasses me and
others
calling our phones repeatedly telling us
to come in
on our days off and lee's voicemails
saying
we are ignoring him jesus christ my
[ __ ] day off anyways he goes recently
he got the only cool management manager
fired
because he said he was stealing
i don't really need this job but would
like to keep working here but don't know
how much longer i can take this any
advice on what i should do
would be appreciated uh sorry for it
being so long go [ __ ] yourself uh it
wasn't long at all
it just sounded long the way i read um
well if you don't need the job then i
would i would quit
but what i wouldn't do is i wouldn't
leave
on bad terms i don't know is it really
going to matter
it's not like when you're 30 if you're
looking for a new job you're going to
put on your resume i worked at the
finish line
because at that point you're going to be
into a career
i don't you say i don't really need this
job but would like to keep working here
but don't know oh so
basically saying you like having walk
around money well i would just get
another job
just get another job start the process
of getting the [ __ ] out of there
like nothing you're going to say to that
guy is going to change that guy and all
that guy can do is kind of make your
life difficult
if you're trying to get another job at
this point in your life
just know that like he's at the tip of
the iceberg of the awful life that he's
going to be living
um like the just
what the way he's setting the table you
don't need to do anything to him because
he's gonna do it to himself
and it would really be bad if if this
guy was just such a negative force you
somehow got sucked into it i know you
probably fantasized
about punching him in the face or
telling the guy to go [ __ ] himself
and then the girl that you have the
crush on at the finish line walks out
arm in arm with you guys and you start
your own sneaker store right across
and you watch him get fired i know
you've probably played that fantasy out
in your head a hundred times but uh i
would just get another job
it sounds like you don't mind working
you're not afraid of working you like
having the money but you just can't deal
with this douche so this is a great life
lesson
you do not need to be surrounded by
douches you have the power it's your
[ __ ] life
just he's always going to be a douche
just walk out of his life just be like
yeah you know i don't need to be around
this guy
you know and then one day when you run
into him after you get another job
hey how come you uh left and just be
like you know because uh
i don't know dude you were just and
don't curse at him or anything because
then
it gives him an excuse
to not see himself and just be like i
don't know man you the
you just kind of creep me out the way
you were always hitting on girls who
were like 16 or 17 years old i mean if
that's what you want to do i mean you
know
that's cool but uh you know i'm just
kind of not into that
so uh you have yourself a nice evening
you just walk away from maybe it'll work
out like that
i have no idea but uh i try and get
yourself another job all right
there you go that's my advice all right
here's another next one uh multiple
[ __ ] buddies gone wrong you know what
dude just the fact that you had
multiple [ __ ] buddies uh
it's it's still a win you know what i
mean
it's still a win you made the playoffs
um hey billy boy first time
long time i got i'm gonna get right into
it all right last weekend i got a text
from a former [ __ ] buddy who found out
that i had slept with their friend
before we started hooking up oh you know
what go [ __ ] yourself
all right you're crushing ass all over
the place you don't need my advice i
probably need advice from you
that's only that's a secret goal of a
certain percentage of guys
is like what if i can [ __ ] her and all
of her friends before they all figure it
out
you know what i mean it's sort of like
an action movie with your dick
and
can i stick it in all of them before the
bomb goes off
and uh and can i get out of town like
[ __ ] de niro and heat
before i see all of them coming up
with the how dare you have you ever
fantasized
about doing that and you were so good
that as mad as they were they all
reminisced about how great you were
and then all four of them come over and
be like ah we're all [ __ ] at the same
time
if you haven't had that fantasy god
bless you because you're evidently a way
more decent a human being than i
am so anyways with that
here we go um he goes she sends me
anyway let me just refresh your memory
here last weekend i got a text from a
former [ __ ] buddy who found out that i
had slept with her friend
before we started hooking up she sends
me a pretty heated two-page text
about how much of a dog and douchebag i
am
for sleeping with her friend then
[ __ ] her the same weekend
yeah dude dude you're a legend you're a
[ __ ] legend what is the
dude all you can do is just stand there
with your hand at your sides
take the slap to the face and just know
that yeah you're a hero
dude you banged her friend and and her
in the same weekend and you're you're
you you don't front a rock a successful
band i mean that's that's
you know my hat's off to you sir
hats off to you anyways he goes now in
reality
i had slept with the friend in late may
and then starting hook
hooking up with the [ __ ] buddy in early
september oh okay so she tried to make
it more dramatic that's still great dude
you you seamlessly made the shift over
the summer
you're still a hero anyways he goes
to go into a little more detail the [ __ ]
buddy had gone on several dates
and [ __ ] once three oh i had gone on
several dates with her and [ __ ] once
three years prior when we were both at
college
but then shortly after she lost interest
and we remained
as friends for the next few years when i
say friends i mean the occasional text
and seeing each other maybe three or
four times
all right so what is your [ __ ]
problem
what is the rule shouldn't shouldn't the
second one be mad at you because you
[ __ ] the other one first
i don't i'll never understand
i never understand what can any female
if you're still listening at this point
if i have any female listeners at this
point can you explain to me
why that makes you mad
you know because i don't know there was
always like
there was always that girl that like you
know when i was growing up like
i can't say me because i wasn't getting
anything i didn't get anything in high
school
big [ __ ] goose egg i would make my
my [ __ ] getting career in high school i
was like
the first year the tampa bay buccaneers
came in the league
and went winless
what was the name of there gary huff
was that the name of their quarterback
that was the gary huff of of [ __ ] in
in in high school whatever the hell are
you that can't remember the name
his last name was huff was the name of
their quarterback with cream sickle
[ __ ] uniform
i mean i had a suit made out of that
when i was in high school um
i but anyways there were there were
those girls that like
my drinking body crew like three or four
of them
out of the five had all hooked up with
her
and none of them were none of nobody was
mad everybody high fives [ __ ] great
that's you know we thought it was a
great thing i don't understand why they
get so mad
you know what it is is i just think that
they want to uh
it's a big thing with them that that has
to be difficult
and you know and if they i think they
just feel like
if you bang them and their friend
they just somehow feel like maybe it
makes them feel cheaper
that there's you're just [ __ ] hitting
it's like you're a machine gun you're
just mowing them down i think that they
really want to believe that they're the
only one in that area code
you know that they're like uh
that it's like gold rather than like
pine cones
[Laughter]
[Music]
you got to dig for it it's precious
metal they don't they
they don't want to feel like they're
just like litter in the gutter
maybe that's what i have no i have no
idea but i have learned something in
this [ __ ] buddy is two words
this guy put [ __ ] buddy together um
that's how much he's into sex right now
he's
he's literally like the [ __ ] is is god
the buddy part bent over
and it's all one word they are one um
so anyways he said to go into a little
more detail i already read that part he
said so fast forward three years
and the friend of hers that's the future
[ __ ] buddy
said that we should hang out after the
sox game
all right i'm getting lost in this with
all my rambling
you know what the [ __ ] so you hooked up
with the former [ __ ] buddy
so now okay so this is when when when
number two comes in
before you went back to number one
all right so fast forward three years
later yes so she didn't give a [ __ ]
so who she should be mad at is the
second one no but it's been three years
you know i really don't think anybody
has a right to be mad here
all right whatever we should hang out
after a sox game of course i see this is
a green light because whenever a girl
that you really don't know says we
should hang out is coz for i'm down to
[ __ ]
exactly did you hear that uh guy with
the [ __ ]
bassoon you got they they speak in code
we should hang out sometime that that's
literally that's what that means
if they say would you everything you're
taking me out that means they want a
relationship we should hang out sometime
that's what that means okay and i'm not
saying a hundred percent
i'm just saying it's it's looking good
you're getting waved around by the third
base
coach um anyways
where the hell am oh for [ __ ] sakes i
i apologize guys
when a girl says that you don't [ __ ] so
oh so anyway so we end up [ __ ]
and she gets on a plane the next day to
study abroad in europe for the summer
exactly she wanted some shoving off dick
you know let me get a little last piece
of america before i go over to europe
tremendous anyways fast forward three
months later and the [ __ ] buddy
all one word says that i should come
over
some weekend to hang out green light we
bang it's great and we continue to do it
until the end of the month when i fly
back
to the place that i now live so a few
days ago i get the heated text saying
i'm a dog i'm a douche bag and she
thought i was a friend
etc i say that there's nothing i can do
or say to change what happened
and the only thing that i could say is
i'm sorry if i heard her and that i am
an [ __ ]
but my question to you uh
mr no relationship psychology degree
comedian
is am i a dog for what i did
no you're not
you're not and [ __ ] these women who call
you up and use you like a [ __ ] stick
all right they called you up because
they wanted some dick and you gave it to
him all right you gave him what the [ __ ]
they asked for
and then she's gonna turn around and get
mad at you
and then you apologize and say yeah i'm
an [ __ ] you're not an [ __ ] but you
know something
i don't think you think you're an
[ __ ] because you're out there
crushing it you're just [ __ ] saying
what you know this girl wants to hear
because probably six months from now
she's gonna [ __ ] you again
right you're not an [ __ ]
you didn't hit on the other girl she
said hey we should hang out sometime
okay she's giving you the green light
you know what i mean you're a guy you
have to take that
you got to take it women don't
understand that because they can get
laid every night of the [ __ ] week if
they want to they don't have to have any
game
and they it for us it's it's it's work
it's a skill okay so when somebody when
if it's like you're in the wild you got
a free [ __ ] meal you're gonna take it
you know i learned that in australia
when i was looking at those poisonous
snakes and like why does that thing have
enough venom
to kill 200 mice why does it need that
much venom it's because it's out there
in the [ __ ]
the outback and out in the outback food
is scarce
so if you get a shot at something you
got to [ __ ] take it down and that's
what the hell you did
yeah i'm a [ __ ] dog you know it's
like you know what [ __ ] you lady
i'm a dog then then you're a [ __ ]
if i'm a dog you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] did
i call you up
did i come around sniffing up your skirt
no you called me
because you wanted some dick and i gave
it to you how about a [ __ ] thank you
letter
dude you really should have come at her
like that you really should have and i
got to tell you something on some
[ __ ] up levels she would actually
respect you as long as you didn't call
don't call her a [ __ ]
all right but she [ __ ] she so
what what is her relationship with you
you guys barely talk and like whenever
she's in a dick dry spell she [ __ ]
goes over to you like your hurts rent a
car and just [ __ ] just rides your
dick
and then you're supposed to be exclusive
and not bang a friend who's cut from the
same cloth
who wants to get plowed before she goes
over to europe this is your [ __ ]
fault
you're the one who should feel used
you know neither one of them wants a
meaningful relationship with you
hey you know what this is what i say
just don't even write them back and you
know something
[ __ ] them again just
bang them again dude who gives a [ __ ]
next time you see her she wants to give
you a dirty look just like
i i don't even react to it what what
what a [ __ ]
what a bunch of [ __ ]
and i got i can't believe that like you
we don't have a relationship
i'm just gonna keep saying the same
thing [ __ ] over and over again why
don't i
let me i'm stuttering here
you know the other day i was watching uh
when i was watching the texans when the
patriots played the texans monday night
football right
and uh some lady
at the at the at the was watching with
us
and she started giving bobcraft [ __ ]
for having like uh a 35 year old
girlfriend
and for those who don't watch football
bob craft was married forever had a
family and his uh wife unfortunately
uh died of cancer you know
so she dies at cancer you know he stuck
by her side did the whole damn thing
and then now he's got a new girlfriend
and she's 35 and women are mad they're
upset about they're upset by and i i
don't uh
i don't get it you know
if i die of a disease i i don't want
[ __ ] near to be sitting here like
some spinster
go on go have a good time i'm dead i
don't give a [ __ ]
you know unless i'm a ghost
i'm sitting there watching it then i
wouldn't like it
but i would just fly away why'd i sit
there watching it
you know start haunting them every time
they were going to have sex i wouldn't
do that to somebody
i just don't understand why like um it's
not like he went out and got with like a
18 19 20 21 year old girl she's 35
35 at 35 if women aren't married they're
freaking out
right they look
i you know what i love i just love that
they get mad at the guy and it's like
what about the girl why is she with them
okay if he's some sort of like you know
oh he's just there
because he wants a hot girlfriend then
what about her she's just there for the
money so then it works out
doesn't it i don't know when whenever
like [ __ ] like that goes on that really
taps into the cynical part of me
which you know if you listen to this
podcast god knows it doesn't take much
but um
sometimes i just i just think that it
almost taps into that [ __ ] buddy thing
they just don't want to know how easily
that they could be replaced
yet they want you to feel
they don't give a [ __ ] if they if they
try and make you feel that way all those
stupid songs
beyonce that that to the left to the
left
you know that whole song is like yeah
just take your [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here i'll have another guy in two
seconds
you're that easily replaced
you know and they they love those songs
those songs are
they consider them [ __ ] empowering
but then when they see a successful guy
with an you know a nice closet full of
shiny ties and his own sports team
when they see that he can still [ __ ]
pull down some 35 year old ass
they get mad they start judging his
character
even me and my mom we had that
discussion well i just don't think that
that's
that just i'm sure that there was
somebody
in their 50s that he could have who the
[ __ ] wants to get with a 50 year old
even if you're 70.
you know
i don't [ __ ] you know what i mean you
know you're starting over again
if you got a [ __ ] old car and you
trade it in
you don't trade it in on a [ __ ]
another old car you get a new one
you know you [ __ ] ride that thing
into the ground and then you get another
one i don't know
i'm just saying i don't have a [ __ ]
problem with what the guy's doing
all right that's it all right everybody
if you like if you enjoyed this podcast
um and you'd like to support the podcast
and in a roundabout way
support the wounded warriors project go
to billboard.com click on the podcast
page and click on
uh the amazon link if you're gonna buy
anything on amazon not saying you have
to but if you got to buy something just
go and buy it doesn't change the price
but uh because you went through my
website they gave me a little kickback
and then i take a portion of those
proceeds
and i give it to the wounded warriors
project so everybody wins
you're helping out the podcast and more
importantly you're helping out the
troops
and then that seems i'm kind of whoring
out their plight to increase
money that i'm making i don't know
there's something wrong about that whole
thing i don't know i'm doing a good
thing but this is just the way that
whole thing's set up but i i'm almost
doing like what the nfl's doing with
with that pink [ __ ]
you know what i mean instead of telling
people the foods that they can eat
to knock down the potential of getting
cancer they just have everybody running
around there dressed like a barbie doll
i don't i don't get it
and i'm guessing somebody's making some
money off of it all right
that's all i'm saying um all right
that's the podcast for this week
everybody that's the pod p
a w d cast that's the podcast for this
week thank you guys so much for
listening
um nhl hockey i have given up on you
i've given up on you i've i've
threatened that i was going to get the
uh whatever the [ __ ] the nba packages
and they had it for free for two three
days which was a great idea and i
watched it and i'm enjoying watching the
knicks
my celtics and watching the lakers lose
and i'm just well i guess i get the
lakers game out here all the time
you know bill russell wrote some book
basically describing
how he made the guys around him on his
team better
and i was reading this bill simmons
article it was making me sick to my
stomach because
i i couldn't finish reading it because i
think kobe is reading it
which would really be devastating
because i don't think kobe has ever
progressed
beyond where michael j michael jackson
michael jordan was
in about 1989 when michael was trying to
do it all himself
and there's nothing better as a celtics
fan
that when phil jackson isn't coaching
and kobe is just trying to do it all
himself
there's nothing [ __ ] better because
he's going to score 30
and they're going to lose and that's
what i love seeing
[Laughter]
wouldn't that be ironic if it took a
celtic to teach a laker how to [ __ ]
win wouldn't that be something
all right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week